[Music]
this is a fascinating uh idea for a
documentary comic con is huge amazing
and the thing is nobody has done this
before and then i found out that you're
really the first person that's been
allowed to shoot at comic con yeah like
people people have tried to make this
movie for like two decades and they've
always said no and uh i was there i met
stan lee two years ago three years ago
when we were there family of marvel
comics family and creator of spider-man
the x-men and i went over to introduce
myself to tell him how i was a kid you
know his comic books changed my life you
know they made me want to tell my own
stories and he goes oh my gosh morgan
that's so nice of you you know we should
make a movie together we should make a
documentary we should make a documentary
about comic con and i was like yes we
should mr lee yes we should so he gave
you permission he got you in literally
like a year later we were making this
film with him with joss whedon with stan
with thomas toll from legendary pictures
i mean it was amazing now what's
interesting is that you see a lot of
elaborate costumes i i went to comic-con
for the first time i think a year and a
half ago and it was quite an experience
you see amazingly elaborate costumes but
there's a spectrum people that have like
spent
months designing their costumes and then
people that clearly
fashioned them in the parking lot
on the way in did you notice that yeah i
know there's people who like and then
there's the people who create their own
characters you know like i'm super
torpedo man and then they give you the
whole backstory you know i'm forgot to
use deodorant man and which it's filled
with those people and then there's like
the guys like my two favorites there was
a guy in a with like a white bucket and
a guy with a red bucket over their heads
just buckets just buckets white and red
buckets and they photocopied like a
stormtrooper face and put on the white
one and and they photocopied like iron
man and put on the red bucket i was like
yeah you guys didn't really try did you
you didn't even really didn't really go
for it it's just the slacker going to
comic con we won't even put effort into
that yeah the uh there there's an
intensity of emotion there amazing uh a
guy that kevin smith had a panel and a
guy uh proposed to his girlfriend that's
right and were they in costume as
characters no they they weren't but they
you know they met and they fell in love
because of all their same kind of geek
passion so he wanted to propose to her
at comic-con so he went online
and got the the engagement ring that he
gave was made by the same people that
make the lord of the rings rings
and so so he gave her like you know the
one ring to rule them all and uh so
isn't that a ring that destroys people's
lives
that doesn't make sense but that's put
that on my path
that's not what you give someone when
you love
are there a lot of uh i've always been
fascinated uh there's a lot of i'm
imagining some pent-up sexual
frustration there and then people are in
revealing costumes is there stuff going
on that we don't know like people talked
about this they were like oh you got to
go to the late night parties and i'm
really good at like finding weird [ __ ]
like i can find weird things all the but
i couldn't find these late night parties
like i was looking for like the late
night wonder woman hookup party or like
the or like the wookie lovin you know
like i want why do you want
all wookies do is have orgasms yeah
fill out this form
[Laughter]
wow okay and so you found no evidence of
a wonder woman key party or a spiderman
party or anything not i wanted to i
wanted to find that batman party you
showed a laurie in the uh in the show
you should work that into your
documentary it's too late now right now
but that's the only existing footage
yeah that'll be comic code episode five
of a batman bane hookup